[Music]
great news too after exhaustive casting
we found heck yeah
Gobber actually I wanted to ask you
about the whole hiccup character in the
story pickup
what is that yourself
tuffnut tuffnut give us a taste yeah a
dragon is coming ah help me help line me
write me are you great now let's see you
run away and fear the split heat of a
newborn while I do not run like that do
I run like that which brings me to a
bigger point I've read the script -
Gobber and I have some notes I'm not
sure the character of hiccup is coming
through quite as heroic as I was I was
pretty heroic no no I think we gonna
just a minute that's not in any way me
hey hiccup I was oh are you serious
[Music]
bad luck next a Magus and they say for
who's next
Fishlegs Inkerman reading for the role
of stoic the vast if I don't return hmm
if I don't return you know that all I am
all I Q is for you
so you know thinking what I'm thinking
yes I this isn't working what not
working you're right
I should do it no no don't try to talk
me out of it I just do it best
if I join your red tongue oh oh
[Music]
the pageant's tonight so are you sure
you're gonna be able to do this I hope
it wasn't noticeable you know it is but
Gobber
think of the kids we're doing this for
them hiccup brilliant as always
[Music]
okay people do manage to gotten
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]